[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit a dit le général de Gaulle de
reconnaître le monde tel qu'il est et
dans ce sens il n'est pas possible
d'oublier à l'autre extrémité du
continent européen asiatique cette Chine
ce très vaste pays géographiquement
compact et pourtant sans unité un état
plus ancien que l'histoire ou un grand
peuple le plus nombreux de la terre
abâti une très particulière et très
profonde civilisation qui conjugue le
goût de la tradition avec le respect de
l'étude et de la science ce peuple
conscient et orgueilleux d'une immuable
pérenité la Chine de
toujours cette Chine de 700 millions
d'êtres qui est aujourd'hui celle qu'a
fait au prix de terrible souffrances
humaines et d'une implacable contrainte
des masses maotsetou il nétait cependant
voici 16 ans qu'un chef de partie vaincu
lorsque le rencontra notre reporter dans
les cavernes de Yenan après cette
retraite historique de 10000 km qu'on a
nommé la longue marche un an après il
entraite à Pékin et installé le régime
communiste sur la Chine
entière depuis un énorme effort a été
accompli le palais des Fils du Ciel au
cœur de la ville interdite voisine avec
un nouveau Pékin moderne ou si les
voitures sont rares les immeubles ont
poussé de toutes parts pour abriter une
population chaque jour plus
nombreuse le pantalon et la veste bleue
ont remplacé pour tous hommes femmes et
enfants les vêures multicolor
d'autrefois la hantise de l'hygiène et
la lutte contre les épidémies la lutte
contre la faim endémique et le
développement des possibilités agricoles
ont pris la première place dans les
préoccupations publiques cet immense
effor s manifesté dans dans tous les
domaines si l'on compte encore les
usines les communications et les travaux
d'irrigation ont commencé à changer le
visage de la très ancienne terre de
Chine comment laisser à l'écart cet
immense pays en pleine évolution ce
peuple innombrable en marche c'est ce
qui apparaît avec le poids de l'évidence
et de la raison ce vide la France va le
combler renouant ainsi avec un peuple
dont la capacité patiente et laborieuse
a toujours suscité l'admiration et qui
est capable de déployer des trésors de
courage et d'ingéniosité quelles que soi
les
circonstances ce langage le général de
Gaulle l'a tenu devant un millier de
journaliste parlant de
l'Asie sur ce continent il n'y a pas une
paix et il n'y a pas une guerre
imaginable sans qu'elle y soit
impliqué et il est
inconcevable de supposer qu'on puisse
jamais conclure
un traité de
neutralité
concernant les États du Sud-Est
asiatique auquel nous Français portons
une attention toute spéciale et
cordiale sans que la Chine en soit
partie neutralité qui paraît bien dans
la période où nous
sommes être la seule situation qui soit
compatible avec la vie paisible et le
progrès des
populations il est
clair que la
France doit pouvoir entendre directement
la Chine et aussi s'en faire
écouter mais il se peut
aussi que dans l'immense évolution
actuelle du monde
en
multipliant les contacts directs de
peuple à peuple on serve la cause des
hommes c'est-à-dire celle de la sagesse
du progrès et de la
paix puis le général de Gaulle envent au
problème de sa succession à la
présidence de la République vous m'avez
demandé
monsieur ce que je ferai dans 2
ans je je ne peux pas et je ne veux pas
vous
répondre alors comme ça pour vous
monsieur X ce sera le général de Gaulle
[Musique]
mesam les statutes monumentales de Rams
2 et les temples d'Abou Simbel dont
elles défendent l'entrée depuis plus de
3 millénair ne seront pas engloutis sous
66 m d'eau après la mise en service du
barrage
d'Assouan l'opération de sauvetage
lancée par l'UNESCO est aujourd'hui
passée dans dans sa phase active les
temples sont entre les mains des
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maîtres mais il faudra de 5 à 7 années
encore pour mener à bien ce nouveau
travail d'Hercule qui coûtera 18
milliards d'anciens francs et qui sera
la plus impressionnante entreprise du
genre de tous les temps il s'agite en
effet de surélever toute la masse des
temples au-dessus du niveau du futur lac
[Musique]
artificiel
devant la fusée Saturne installée sur sa
rampe de lancement à Cap Kennedy devant
cette masse haute de 51 m et lourde de
562 tonnes les techniciens américains
ont pu avoir la sensation de vivre un
moment historique de la course pour
l'espace ils étaient TR pour surveiller
le lancement de ce géant qui mettait
enfin les États-Unis à égalité avec
l'URSS utilisant l'hydrogène liquide
pour l'alimentation des six moteurs du
second étage saturne est en effet la
première fusée qui é é capable de
satelliser 17 tonnes et le président
Johnson en assistant devant son poste de
télévision au succès du lancement a pu
mesurer le chemin parcouru depuis les
déboires du célèbre pamplemousse qui fit
si triste mine 3 mois après le premier
spoutnic Gaston nessins a quitter la
Corse pour se rendre à Paris à la
convocation du juge d'instruction
pourtant Monsieur Daniel Davy qui lui
offrait de venir travailler en Écosse
est venu lui renouveler sa proposition
et à l'aérodrome de Bastia où il a
embrassé sa femme et sa fillette 400 éta
ven le saluer 400 personnes qui
entretiennent encore autour de
l'anablast l'espoir insensé d'une
[Musique]
guérison mais à Paris Gaston nessin
n'était plus que le
pseudobiologiste attendu par le juge
Rousel qui lui notifia l'inculpation
d'exercice illégal de la médecine et de
la
[Musique]
pharmacie
c'est en présence de 50000 personnes que
s'est déroulé l'ouverture des 9e Jeux
olympiques d'hiver àbr le docteur Charf
président de la République autrichienne
a accueilli les représentants des 36
nations participantes avant l'envoi des
couleurs et la cérémonie du flambau
olympique un couple heureux parmi la
foule l'Impératrice faradiba et le chat
[Musique]
d'Iran les jeux sont ouverts les
premières épreuves débutent par une
surprise en patinage artique attend le
couple champion du monde les Allemands
Mar Kus
etanler ce ne sont pas eux qui ont
remporté la médaille d'or les vainqueurs
vous les voyez en ce moment ce sont les
Soviétiques de leningrade ludmiaova ETG
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
protop mais ce sont surtout les épreuves
de skon
attendait
concur malchanceux a PR l'allure d'un
feu d'artifice avec bien entendu le
grand soleil le français JeanClaude a
été la victime numéro 1 de ce fe
[Musique]
d'artifice mais la déception a été
largement compensé par la Cour de lo
laro que voici en pleine
[Musique]
action sil avit cravantage à la victoire
Léo laro aurait pu être champion
olympique de la descente il termine à 74
C seulement du vainur
l'autrichi
on cimmerman a confirmé qu'il est bien
cette année le meilleur descendeur du
monde dans cette spécialité il est quasi
imbattableimerman je suis content
d'avoir gagné la croix j'espère faire
mieux la prochaine fois mais chez les
skilleuses pas de problème les sœurs
guadchell se partagent à de toute la
gloire à part égal au slalom spécial
Marielle la cadette dossard numéro 1
gagne la première manche dans un style
éblouissant elle est si parfaite qu'on
na pas l'impression qu'elle force son
[Musique]
talent un mois la deuxième manche
s'empresse de rétorquer Christine l'aîné
qui devient finalement championne
olympique du spécial casselan tienne
Mariel sera elle aussi championne
olympique 2 jours plus tard du slalom
géant devant sa sœur
justement avec ces deux jeunes filles
prodiges les résultats c'est blanc
bonnet bonnet blanc pour la plus grande
gloire du Ski Français qui est devenu
àbr le premier du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monde